Hace unos meses sacamos éste vídeo en
el que hablábamos del milagro
económico de Singapur.
Mucha gente considera este país un
modelo a seguir y lo cierto es que hay
que reconocerles que en muy poquito tiempo
han sido capaces de pasar de ser un
pueblo de pescadores por debajo del
umbral de la pobreza a ser uno de los
tres países más ricos del planeta. Pero
esperad un momento porque Singapur
está muy lejos de ser ese paraíso de
libertades que muchos piensan.
Para que os hagáis una idea: el chicle o la goma
de mascar está terminantemente
prohibida en este país. Es más, si te
pillan importando chicle a Singapur
te puede caer una multa de hasta
100.000 dólares o incluso dos años de
cárcel. Por supuesto, si la policía te
pillan escupiendo a chicle por la calle
la multa asciende a los 700 dólares.
Y todo esto ¿por qué? Pues porque el
gobierno de Singapur entiende que el
chicle es algo muy poco higiénico, muy
poco saludable que ensucia las ciudades,
y que además puede crear grandes
problemas si la gente los colocan en las
cerraduras o en los aparatos
electrónicos. Pero esto es sólo un
ejemplo, hoy vamos a ver la otra cara de
Singapur y creerme: hay para rato.
Lo primero que tenemos que entender a la
hora de hablar de Singapur es que es el
resultado del sueño de un hombre: Lee Kuan Yew, el auténtico padre de la patria.
Lee Kuan Yew fue el artífice de la
independencia de este país y, además, el
Presidente del mismo durante 31 años.
- " ¿Nunca has tenido un momento en el
que pensarás que Singapur era demasiado autoritaria?
No, mi trabajo es mantener el camino del
país y garantizar que todo el mundo
tiene una vida decente y educación;
y ahora son los más educados de todo el
este de asia".
Lee Kuan Yew quería construir una sociedad
utópica, donde todo el mundo fuera rico,
estuviera bien educado, fuera respetuoso
con los demás y, por supuesto, no tuviera
ningún vicio. Y eso explica cosas como
ésta:
Normalmente a los
dictadores les gusta limitar la libertad
de expresión para poder oprimir a una
minoría religiosa o consolidar sus
privilegios y los de su familia. En
Arabia Saudí persiguen a todos
aquellos que ofendan al islam pero no
protegen igualmente al resto de
religiones.
Lo mismo ocurre en Guinea Ecuatorial
donde no puedes insultar a su dictador,
Teodoro Obiang, pero sí que puedes
insultar a otros políticos extranjeros
o incluso de la oposición.
Sin embargo, en Singapur la censura
existe para garantizar que nadie se
salte los cánones de la corrección
política.
No olvidéis que en este país de cinco
millones de habitantes tenemos a todas
las razas incluidas: hay europeos, chinos,
malayos, etcétera.
- "No tenemos inestabilidad,
tenemos a distintas razas conviviendo
pacíficamente, diferentes religiones
pero no hay choques".
No sólo eso, es que,
además, en Singapur no se puede ofender
a ninguna religión.
Da igual que sea el cristianismo, el
islam, el budismo o la cienciología.
Y, por supuesto, tampoco se puede criticar
al gobierno ni a la sagrada figura de
Lee Kuan Yew.
"- Amos Yee pasará seis semanas en la cárcel y
pagar una multa tras ser declarado
culpable de haber herido sentimientos
religiosos". Y algunos pensaréis que esta
falta de libertad de expresión fomenta
que haya mucha corrupción en el
gobierno de Singapur ¿verdad? Lo cierto es
que ser un político corrupto es un mal
negocio en este país. Es más, la
policía no necesita pruebas
determinantes para meterte en la cárcel
si te pillan metiendo la mano en la caja.
Y los castigos incluyen cinco años de
cárcel, multas millonarias y por
supuesto latigazos. De eso vamos a hablar
en un par de minutos.
Ahora bien, esta falta de libertad de
expresión sí que explica porque
Lee Kuan Yew pudo mantenerse en el poder
durante más de 30 años. Y su partido
político, el "Partido de la Acción
Popular" tiene más del 70 por ciento de
los escaños del Parlamento.
Es más, incluso después de su muerte
está terminantemente prohibido criticar,
ofender o siquiera hacer chistes sobre
la figura de nuestro amigo Lee Kuan Yew.
Sí, esto que está sonando ahora mismo es
"Parálisis Permanente" un grupo mítico
español de los años ochenta. Y es que
no me he podido evitar ponerlo para
hablar de cosas como estas:
- "Dos alemanes sentenciados a azotamiento y
nueve meses de prisión por hacer un
grafiti en un vagón de tren".
Efectivamente, Singapur es uno de los
pocos países del mundo donde existen
penas de azotamiento.
Es decir, no es que los policías
maltraten a los reclusos, es que en el
propio código penal singapurense está
estipulada la pena por azotes propinados
con una vara. Así que si te condenan por
vandalismo, por ejemplo, te pueden caer 6,
7,8,9 azotes o los que sean. Y no os
creáis que es una práctica anecdótica.
Sólo en el año 2012 se aplicó este
tipo de castigo más de dos mil
doscientas veces. Y por supuesto el
código penal de Singapur  también
incluye la pena de muerte. Y a diferencia
de otros países como Estados Unidos que
también tiene pena capital en distintas
regiones, en esta ciudad estado se puede
aplicar a crímenes como, por ejemplo, el
narcotráfico.
- "Una muerte es incluso
suave, porque los traficantes están
matando familias enteras todos los días,
durante años,
cada vez que una hija o un hijo se
vuelve un adicto". Pero, ojo, antes de
criticarlo
tenemos que reconocer que todos los
países de la región aplican las mismas
penas contra los narcotraficantes: desde
Indonesia, Malasia, Filipinas y por
supuesto China. Pero esperad porque
todavía hay más
libertades personales como os decía al
principio singapur parece seguir al pie
de la letra la filosofía de jóvenes
cuando decía eso de que el hombre es un
lobo para el hombre y necesita
restricciones para no caer en los vicios
por esta razón la venta de pornografía
está prohibida en singapur aunque
gracias a internet sus ciudadanos ya
pueden visitar páginas de contenido
para adultos
pero no sólo es la pornografía
también hablamos de otras cosas como el
consumo de chicle o goma de mascar que
está considerado un hábito muy poco
higiénico y por tanto está prohibido
pero si éstos parece poco tenemos
prohibiciones aún más absurdas como la
de estar desnuda en tu propia casa por
lo que te pueden caer multas de hasta
2.000 dólares y os preguntaréis cómo
es posible que un país que persigue
tanto el vicio sea famoso por tener dos
de los casinos más grandes del mundo
parece un poco raro que un país que es
tan estricto con otras cosas permita que
sus ciudadanos se dejen sus ahorros
jugando a la ruleta verdad lo cierto es
que miles de ciudadanos vienen a
singapur cada año a jugar al plantear
la ruleta rusa güell poco le vale vale
ya sé que he metido la pata en singapur
más se juega a la ruleta rusa solamente
juegan a la ruleta normal pero sus
ciudadanos es decir los naturales de
singapur tienen que pagar un impuesto
especial si quieren entrar en estos
casinos es decir que el gobierno protege
a sus propios ciudadanos de sí mismos
pero esperado momento porque hay un
área donde singapur es
sorprendentemente abierto algo así como
una válvula de escape para los vicios
de los singapurenses
sí estoy hablando de la prostitución
que a diferencia de otros países como
suecia francia o españa en singapur
está reconocida y regulada
cada día este fin a singapur cuenta con
más de 6 mil prostitutas y llegó los
registrados
estas profesionales del sexo están
obligados a hacerse chequeos médicos de
forma periódica
además la ley de prostitución
singapurense prohíbe expresamente el
proxenetismo
es decir que si tú quieres puedes
practicar el oficio pero no puedes
cantar tu propio purda del y tener a
trabajadores sexuales en tu plantilla y
tampoco se te permite ofrecer tus
servicios en la calle de forma
explícita a no ser que estés en ese
barrio donde se concentran todos los
lupanares de la ciudad
hablamos del distrito de yale han
presentaron última
r
dos de los grandes poderes
cercada por cierto que está tan
afrodisíaco que está sonando es la
música de rick un cantante compositor y
guitarrista colombiano que nos ha
enviado su música
si os gusta podéis encontrar más en
los links de la descripción con cada
golpe pero espera de un momento porque
pese a todas estas regulaciones singapur
no ha conseguido evitar que existan
muchísimos casos de prostitución
ilegal que es la que se alimenta de
todas estas redes de trata de blancas
no tenemos cifras exactas sobre el
número de inmigrantes que han sido
explotados sexualmente pero sabemos que
existen y la prueba es que en el año
el gobierno sacó una ley especial para
prevenir este tipo de casos ha
funcionado no funcionaba
todavía es pronto para decir
eso es la falta de libertad es el precio
que pagan los singapurenses para vivir
en esta utopía
ahora bien tenemos que ser justos porque
el resto de países vecinos de singapur
están muchísimo más atrás en lo que
a libertades individuales se refiere
en malasia la homosexualidad es un
delito lo mismo ocurre en indonesia
donde por cierto también tienen penas
por azotes y todo tipo de castigos
corporales por no hablar de que en
singapur
existe un imperio de la leen y todo
está escrito negro sobre blanco y en el
resto de países vecinos no está tan
claro
las preguntas que es que el régimen de
singapur es sostenible llegarán momento
en el que las autoridades se verán
obligadas a aceptar diversidad de
opiniones y de estilos de vida
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios deiss que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribe a saber canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones o
más siempre si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema
encontrarás varios lynch en la
descripción les ha gustado este vídeo
de alain y nos veamos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto este test